this pair is Craig fuller he'll tell us
about reinforcement learning for
recommender systems Thanks thanks very
much thanks for the invitation I
apologize for not being able to be here
for the whole four days because it looks
like really interesting for us it was
much travel but definitely learned a
little bit about the state of the art
today what I want to talk about is some
work that we've been doing at Google
with a number of collaborators as I go
through a couple of pieces of work I'll
mention the collaborators couple are
here you shy Dale here in the room today
so the work that I've been focused on
over the last little while and and
focusing on my team and some of our
collaborators at Google and beyond has
really been on recommender systems and
the application really one of the things
that motivates me and motivates a lot of
the the work that my team is doing is
the the need that we feel to make our
recommender systems more user centric
right now that's a bit of a buzzword but
what I mean is is simply just a really
simple slogan we want to build
recommenders that really understand a
user's genuine needs goals tasks
preferences and can do a good job of
meeting those meeting those those needs
a subject to those preferences
understanding their task and interacts
with the user in a very natural
unobtrusive and transparent fashion
right now what does that mean that's a
that's that's a mouthful I could
probably spend about 40 minutes just
trying to unpack that but I'll just boil
it down into kind of three main bullets
that that really drive my thinking about
recommender systems first is that we
think we need our recommender systems to
do a better job of understanding user
Layton state we've heard a little bit
about hidden state here today but this
is something I don't think it's enough
attention within the our own community
these days and for users when we're
interacting with users Layton state is
super critical when we're talking about
late and say we can mean you know how
satisfied is user with their product
what are their current preferences what
are their needs what are their interests
what activities are they engaged in as
many of these things are going to be
transient some some are going to be
persistent and extend over long periods
of time
and we really can't act well on behalf
of user without understanding without
understanding that okay the second the
second point here when we talk about
natural interaction with users we're
going to have to take efforts to
estimate react to an influence and in
particular elicit that latent state from
users we're going to have to get crude
signals about what it is that they want
us to accomplish our commanders to
accomplish for them we're going to do
that we're going to have to interact
with our users in a much in a much less
brain-dead fashion than most recommender
currently do we're gonna have to engage
in true multi-turn multimodal
interaction and generally we're gonna
have to engage in dialogue and
conversation and finally we want to do
all of this so that we can really act
any users best incas right that means
not only understanding user preferences
but when we observe their behavior we
when we try to make inferences about
what that reveals about their
preferences we've got to be cognizant of
the fact that how people act and
sometimes not give a true representation
of what what it is that they're trying
to a car okay so these are a lot of
things that that that motivate our work
and it should be pretty clear I think to
everybody here that reinforcement
learning is going to play a central role
in in all of this right if you look at
the first two bullet points for example
that that requires thinking about a
sequential interaction with users and
planning how you gather information how
you talk to them
now I'm gonna give this going to be a
very high-level mostly non-technical
talk feel free to interrupt if you've
got any questions follow the gradient
that Dale said not being theoretical
theoretical but I'll follow that
gradient up to its to its limit so now
the real question is if we are all is
going to play it's gonna have to play a
central role in in all of this but the
real question is why haven't we seen RL
applied successfully maybe in little
bits and pieces a little bit of
Microsoft a little bit of Facebook we've
had a few minor successes I would say I
would say Google but we've despite all
the great successes RL has had in game
playing simulated environments and
robotics to some extent even in physical
control of things like data center
cooling that's some work we've been
doing at Google somewhat surprisingly
we've seen much less success in the
application of our user facing
applications we're talking about say ad
serving or in particular what I'm going
to focus on its recommender systems
right why is that what I'd like to
challenge people to think about is what
is it about these types of problems
which are really important from a
practical perspective that the RL the
the RL research community is is missing
right I don't have solutions to all of
these I'll just pose a couple of these
and talk about some of the starting
points and some of the work that we've
been doing along these but for me you
know where we want to chart like a 5 10
20 year path to really put it really in
front of users on a day to day basis so
what are some of the challenges when we
think about applying reinforcement
learning and user facing systems in
particular and recommender systems right
we often hear about scale because we
haven't talked too much about scale at
this workshop but you know we think
about ogo is such a complex game you
know the you know the number of actions
a number of states when we think about
recommender systems usually we're
talking about systems that are enacting
with millions or billions of users now
interestingly each one of those users
at least that one level of abstraction
is almost like an independent
environment right each user is their own
MDP what the action I take for one user
doesn't influence another user thinking
about ecosystem and game theoretic
effects but I won't talk about that here
today but you know we may have you know
billions of users the number of the
number of actions that we have is often
in the order of many millions if not if
not billions who think about say
recommending videos on YouTube each
possible video in the corpus is an
action that I could take in a
recommender system it's worse than that
because you don't go to YouTube or go to
an e-commerce site and get one item
recommended it's usually packaged
together in a slate you get a bunch of
things right so now we've got this
combinatorial blow up in the action
space that we that we have to deal with
it's really critical from a practical
point of view the second problem is you
don't I do syncretic nature of the of
our action space right we think about a
slate of items that we're putting in
front of you it often doesn't have a
fixed size if users may be scrolling
through their mobile app to find to find
a product how many items are presented
with is often is often dynamically
created and often the set of items that
are recommendable is actually stochastic
there's some exogenous stochastic
process that's generating hey here are
the things that you could recommend
right now and surprisingly from an RL
perspective we really don't think about
problems like that finally and I think
the most important one is dealing with
user latency as I already mentioned you
know we have to we care about a user's
preferences their activities their with
the personality that preferred modes of
interaction and and so on and so forth
and all of those things are really
critical to deciding whether or not this
is a good or bad recommendation if this
is
okay but but because of this we've got a
heat and a tremendous degree of
unobservable 'ti these when we interact
with users from a pom dpph perspective
the the signal that we're getting about
that underlying latent state is really
really small it's a black box and so
many that they can statistically
estimate and be successful I mean so
we're we really wanted to be in that my
goal is to put what I would call
decision support true decision support
tools in the hands of every user right
and everybody and everybody in this room
has very different preferences there's a
lot of commonality and we'll absolutely
want to generalize across using all our
models do but I really want to
understand your preferences and from my
perspective it really requires that I'm
going to have a conversation with you
like a person that was interacting with
you and making recommendations you'd
have no trouble you know our current
recommenders don't do that that that's
the only point that I that I want to
make now does it mean we have to
explicitly represent that latent state
you could you know I'm perfectly fine if
we just take all of that data you know a
user's entire interaction history when
our favorite RNN technology and say hey
I've uncovered a belief state road the
problem is our technologies they're
nowhere near being
I'm okay with that though if that's if
that's if that's the way we do it that's
fine right though we can't
okay so the the key thing I want to
point out that there's a huge degree of
on observability and a huge degree of
stochasticity right so when I recommend
a video on YouTube and the user then
just shuts down the app was it because
they didn't like the video or did
somebody bring the doorbell or did their
kids say hey I need some help with my
homework
right we don't know highly you know
there's so many exogenous factors highly
stochastic so it all ends it all adds up
to a very Hamdi P environment a
partially observable environment which
we have to do RL that is a really low
signal to noise ratio
really really challenging and I'll
explain why we think it's important to
address this of course there's all kinds
of other stuff Dale you've mentioned at
the top of the top of your talk that
there are multi agent interactions we're
very interested in things like fairness
ecosystem dynamics incentive property
some of the game theoretic and
multi-agent aspects as well but I won't
talk about that here oops
page unresponsive
wait oh wait all right so what I'm going
to talk about today I'm just gonna pick
three topics from here on some work that
we've done highlighted in yellow and the
degree of yellow tells you roughly how
much time I'm gonna spend so I'm just
going to give a very high-level overview
of this one idea of stochastic action
sets workday land and each I were
involved in talk very briefly about some
more recent work on on dealing with user
learning and how we handle the low
signal-to-noise ratio this is very
preliminary very far from practice this
is actually quite actually is we do this
in practice and then I'll talk about
some work in a little more detail at the
end on how we're handling the slate
recommendation problem from an RL from
an RL perspective and this is something
that we've also put into so let's start
just really quickly with with this first
problem that of stochastic action sets
okay so it turns out that in a lot of
user-facing systems whether talk about
ad-serving recommender systems that the
set of actions that you're able to take
at any particular state is governed by
some exogenous stochastic process that's
out of your control at least out of the
control of the for instance an ad
auctions because of things like budget
throttling campaign eligibility and
recommender systems because of you know
various candidates and eligibility
criterion what can happen is you can be
facing a user you're given a set of ads
or recommendable items that you can put
in front of the user you go ahead and
you do it
user responds in a certain way maybe
they didn't like that ad end up in a new
state in your MDP you're given another
set another set of that so that you you
can show you should you show on user
responds in a certain way you end up
back in state one or something
equivalent to state one and you get a
completely different set of
this sounds I think Dale you agreed when
we first talked abut this should be a
problem that the our community solved
doesn't decades ago right surprisingly
though the fountain surprisingly though
the foundations for this type of for
this type of model just didn't exist
right but this is this is a problem that
we have to face in practice in
recommender system problem is it doesn't
naturally for it you can't naturally
formulate it as an MDP so it's very hard
to do RL right so we thought about how
would you go about solving a problem
like this you can't it's not a what the
current page okay you know let me just
close a bunch of stuff here there we go
I wasn't actually reading the message
though so how would we go about
formulating a problem like this as an
mdpi and again i'm not going to get into
a lot of technical detail but roughly
speaking there are two ways to do it one
is you know so the process that we're
engaged in we show up in a state and
nature is going to say here are the
actions that you're allowed to play
right now okay so you're at a state s
nature says here's a subset of the Fiza
but here's a subset of the feasible
actions that you're allowed to play okay
alright one way to think of this as an
MDP is this this embed the available
action set within the state space itself
right and then if we know that the if we
know something about the the action
generation distribution or that process
then we can easily build it a transition
model within this embedded state space
okay the problem with this is it blows
up the state space exponentially we have
to have a copy of every state for every
possible subset of actions the second
way to do it is not to blow up the state
space but simply say our actions at a
given state are the set of mappings that
take the available set that's revealed
to us and
tells us what action to play from that
particular avail available set okay and
again if we know what that if we know
what the action generating distribution
is very easy to construct the model now
we didn't blow up the state space with
this factorial blow up in the in the
action space right but both of these
things are now nice mdps right but they
don't look very tractable fortunately
despite this blow up we can show that
the optimal policies and the optimal
value functions of course actually are
provably compactive this really nice
representation yep so just to make sure
that process that's the learning which
actions are feasible is AI is not
influenced by the policy right it
suggests yes exactly yeah it's some
exogenous process that we don't have
control over exactly right okay it's
often the case and say an ad serving
system right
yes Oh in a recommender system I'll get
into that in a little bit more detail
but think of the state as some user
features demographics something about
their context could be the location time
of day something about their historical
interaction anything that we would feed
into a predictive model that'll be the
state okay so if it turns out that
optimal policies in particular always
have this nice decision with structure
in particular we can say say at state s
1 action k1 it should be ordered before
k2 before order before k3 and so on and
so forth and we can do this for every
state we know an optimal policy that
there always exist an optimal policy
with that structure right so for example
so for example if if these two actions
are revealed to me as available at state
s then I would play action k2 because
it's the first one in the available set
that shows up in the ordering okay the
nice thing about this is you can take
advantage of this structure to develop
nice poly time algorithms in particular
we've developed value iteration policy
iteration linear programming method to
solve to solve these problems when the
models given to you most important from
a practical perspective because this is
a situation that we face in add serving
this allows you to decompose something
like Q learning from a practical
perspective I don't have to learn a q
function over this and this expanded
state space I can learn a q function
that's a function of the state and the
individual items and and then choose the
when an available set is revealed to me
I just have to choose the action the
available action that has a maximum that
is exactly the right thing to do just
recently just the summer around ICML
time georgia Steve Kairos folk Thomas
and a couple of others actually start to
develop policy gradient methods for
okay all right so let me move on talk
about I think is maybe a slightly more
interesting problem one that's
completely unresolved and that's some
techniques that we've been starting to
look at for dealing with Hamdi partially
observable environments that have really
low signal-to-noise ratio okay and the
thing that motivated us to think about
this problem is a phenomenon that we've
observed in recommender systems and in
ad-serving systems that's a phenomenon
of phenomenon of user learning that
users will learn to adapt to a change in
your recommendation policy but over a
really long slow slow horizon right so
this is this is a plot from a some from
some Google folks let me know talk about
this this isn't an ad serving context
but here's some some work that folks in
Google research and and YouTube did just
a couple of years ago where they changed
the policy the YouTube serving policy on
the homepage to show more or less
diverse recommendations within that
slate okay and what we see here in the
in in in with the blue line here what
we're showing what we're seeing is the
percentage increase in the number of
home page visits from the users that are
consistently shown this more given this
more diverse treatment and in green what
you're seeing is users that are given
this diverse treatment just for one day
so there's no cumulative effect right
and then another group of users on the
next day what you see is that the change
in the number of home page visits in the
early stages there's no difference right
so we're having almost no impact on user
but then over this very long horizon and
a point to the scale view this is almost
a four month experiment there's a slow
but consistent and persistent effect
that we're having on the user right now
we believe they're also some exploration
of implicitly but really the users are
learning to adapt to this change right
surveys confirm this said hey user
actually a little more satisfied with
the recommendations that they're getting
but how does it manifest itself in their
behavior in terms of say increased
number of
of homepage visits to YouTube it takes
it takes weeks and months to actually
start to show up and actually converge
right this is going to be problematic
from an RL perspective if we want if we
want to say hey if we showed more
diverse recommendations what's it going
to do to the user if we do it again and
do it again and do it again we're
talking about events with horizons that
are on the order of tens to hundreds of
thousands and from a practical
perspective we can't we can't really
handle that and in particular what's
going on here is these problems have
what I call a really low signal-to-noise
ratio so the first one is is the same
user where you're showing them more
diverse that's right
consistently right so over right so if
you're part of that group every time you
come to YouTube you're getting more
diverse recommendations so we don't want
to just compare it we don't want to just
compare it to kind of what is the what
is the current policy what we're going
to do is take say we're going to take me
today we're going to expose you to more
diverse recommendations and then we
throw you away I mean do you just go
back and do it and then tomorrow I'm
gonna take somebody else tomorrow I'm
gonna take somebody else cuz I want to
see is there a cumulative effect on user
versus just kind of a one shot that was
a diversity being accumulated across my
friend days so you know this is
diversity within that particular slate
of recommendations right so it's an
immediate change to the policy like
here's my state what action do I take
what sleep do it seems
we get your information because the
grain changes jobs otherwise that you
don't have to do the drill you just need
the glue in the first few days say the
green is like the green I'm not sure I'm
not sure not trying I know I know I
don't think I don't I don't I don't
think that's true right I mean these are
highly stochastic process I won't say
how many users or it's a lot but user
behavior is highly so I actually don't
think empirically this variance is
actually increasing I don't have the
stats the back
all right so so what what's going on
here right problems like this they have
a really low signal-to-noise ratio so if
we think about let's suppose it's user
satisfaction that's driving this
increased engagement they increased that
you know return to the YouTube homepage
right first of all it's very clear I
mean I say you're talking about the
variance this in itself has a very noisy
impact on user engagement right it's
just one of other much more dominant
factors that said that that will dictate
how often a user uses right but this
latent state the satisfaction it moves
it it moves very slowly alright but very
persistently so it's really has this law
this significant cumulative effect on
user behavior which we would like to
capture from an RL perspective but it's
gonna be really it's gonna be really
problematic and in particular without
getting into a lot of technical details
I think somebody was talking about
advantages earlier today what happens
from a formal perspective is that the
advantages you so you suppose that we
would suppose if we think about say
let's say satisfaction it's just a
one-dimensional latent state we see here
this is just a synthetic demonstration
of this point that the difference in Q
values between action 1 let's say
showing a diverse slate versus showing a
non-diverse slate the differences in
these advantages is very very small
right but because these are partially
observable latent state problems there's
always going to be state estimation
errors so if you actually say run a Q
learning algorithm even where you get to
observe this latent state so you don't
have to have the estimated but we just
perturb it with a little bit of noise
what you see is that the best action the
read action versus the the vs. of blue
action actually invert right it's really
hard to estimate what the right action
is
so what we've what we've been doing is
developing some techniques and these are
in in their their nascent days right now
to amplify these advantages to make the
control problem in these latent state
problems recency problems much easier
too much easier to solve one technique
we've been looking at is temporal
aggregation so for example if we you
know if we go back if we go go back here
what we see is that you know there's
some small advantage between saying
showing a diverse slate to keep you
satisfied to get them a little more
satisfied versus say a less diverse
slate but if we aggregate this and we
say you know what we're not saying what
the slate is but suppose we just had two
choices of action more diverse less
diverse and how you implement more
diverse if we aggregate it and say you
know what for the next K time steps I'm
gonna show only the more diverse slates
right and then after that I say I'm
going to change my decision for the next
case okay time periods again I'll show
another fixed action just hold back
committed what happens is we we actually
amplify those advantages right and in
the noisy case what happens is we
actually recover the proper ordering of
these actions now again I'm not going to
get into into technical detail be happy
to talk about in offline this turns out
to be especially useful when these user
facing contacts when that latent state
evolved very very slowly right because
what happens suppose that I committed to
an action because it seemed like the
right one but after it but maybe you
know maybe after four or five steps it's
not there it's not right because the
slate state is moving so slowly chances
are if it's not the right action it's
going to be close to being right okay
so guess why I get the ocean what
worries me about this proposal to debate
is if there are actions that can like
the determine the amount of temporal
aggregation what I do might be very
different for different actions as one
of them one of the actions was to just
like often the user you know you're
absolutely right right so this is a
fairly simple stylized stylized model
right you can show under certain
properties of the MDP so this type of
temporal aggregation is going to work
not for R this type of fixing in action
it's not going to work hey you don't
want to fix that video for a while right
but at the right level of abstraction if
we've got the right policy parameters it
can actually work but there are other
things that you can do as well right so
they're actually more that that was just
to illustrate the point right there are
other types of abstraction or
aggregation that you can do you could
have some switching cost so you're not
forcing me to commit to an action but
you just gotta make me pay a cost piece
which they do the same thing using you
know so something like soft policy
regularization at the level of but but
more from the point of view is switching
so I want to keep the same action
distribution and so on I think the more
interesting question though which is why
we think this is a fundamental research
problem is that it really offers a
different motivation for thinking about
hierarchy and macros and options
normally think about options as a
technique for hey this will help me
achieve a sub goal hit a waypoint along
the way
reduce my computational effort somehow
what we think is is that if we can come
up with kind of local policies whose
goal is help us identify that state
amplify that signal to noise ratio over
there let's not worry about sub goal so
something help me figure out where I am
alright that could be very useful
we don't know how to do that yet we're
thinking about these problems okay now
you can do a little bit of theoretical
analysis
it shows some some value but only in
synthetic experiments this is very far
from practice but I think this is one of
the most pressing problems so in the
last oh I think I've got it so about 15
minutes or so I want to talk about the
final piece of work and I'll get into a
little more detail on this depending on
the questions and that's dealing with
Slate recommendations right so any
recommender system that you you've dealt
with you've probably never been shown a
single eye single item recommendation so
usually some collection of items right
by you know by these books watch these
videos here are three music tracks which
one would you like okay and again I
don't I don't don't think I need to
motivate for this crowd why why we want
to optimize over the long term from an
RL perspective you know if we wanted to
formulate this as an MDP its answer your
question about what is the state well we
think about the state again as a
collection of user features you know
elements of their demographics something
about the user's history how we've
interacted with them in the past various
contextual features and so on and so
forth our goal is to maximize some
notion of engagement we want our users
to be engaged with I won't say we do
some I'll talk about some live
experience won't say exactly what the
user engagement metric it is but we did
some some interesting experiments with
YouTube users and our reward is going to
be again a function of this engagement a
gauge Monteux so you know how many
videos did they watch
and now our actions are not gonna be the
individual videos but they're going to
be slates of videos okay and this is
where the combinatorics comes in right
if we've got in recommendable videos and
we've got case case lots that we can
fill we've got this this combinatorial
blow-up in the number of slates that we
can configure okay and this is going to
be problematic for a variety of reasons
first of all from an exploration and
generalization perspective if we just
think of those slates as the items
themselves that have no structure that
we don't try if we don't try to exploit
some structure we've got way too many
actions that we'll be able to it then
we'll be able to explore and we won't
have the appropriate generalization I
mean you could come up with the right
feature representation but we want to do
something a little bit more we're also
gonna have a problem from an
optimization perspective whether we're
doing a policy improvement or a Q
learning Q learning maximization we have
to find the right slate given a
particular state from this from this
huge number ideally what we want to do
is decompose the value of a slate into
something that's a little more traffic
and you'd think well maybe I could just
think about the value of individual
items but the problem is that items on a
slate interact with one another in other
words the presence of one item on a
slate can impact the value or I should
say impact for instance the probability
that the user will select some other
items on the slate and hence will impact
the value of those other items on this
lane for example if I get a slate of
John Oliver video here's a john oliver
video and some other political satire
videos the probability that i'll click
on this video in this slate is probably
pretty different than the probability of
me clicking on it in the in a slate full
of funny cat videos unless you yes
okay so in specifically we want to take
advantage of the fact that the value of
a slate depends on the user choice model
right what is the process by which a
user will select one item from the from
the from the slate of items okay there
are a variety of a variety of user
choice margin common one and in in in
stats and econometrics and the
psychology of choice is just a simple
loose Shepherd or multinomial logit or I
think we're probably a conditional logic
model which simply says give me a slate
a this capital A here in a particular
state s the probability that the user
will select an item I from that slate is
simply the the exponentiated value where
this value may represent some
attractiveness of this item to the user
right a very common choice model but
there many other choice most plaquette
boost cascaded you can the variety of
models that you you could use the point
is when there's this interaction
generally it's going to require joint
optimization obviously so how can we
take advantage of that so we've
developed a technique we call it we call
it slate Q which decomposes the value
the Q value of a slate so this will be a
Q learning technique the Q value of a
slate into item wise Q values and in
particular in this this assumption is is
valid when we make a few just a couple
of specific assumptions about the
dynamics of user choice and how it
influences state evolution I'll get next
slide will say what those two
assumptions are what we're going to do
is learn we'll call them conditional on
click item wise Q values so for every
item on for every item that we could
recommend we're going to learn what is
the value of that item if the long term
value of the item if the user were to
click on it okay
and then the Q value of a slate will be
derived from these item wise Q values in
a very simple tractable way and of
course the values of the slates will
also feed into the learning of the item
wise Q values because we don't see how
users interact with individual items we
see that they interact with slates in
their training
ok so I'm gonna make two simple
assumptions that are relatively
innocuous and hold approximately in
reality that are gonna allow this this
decomposition to work okay
the first is that when the user is
presented with a slate they're gonna
select only one item from that slate
okay
that's actually the case for instance in
YouTube well now you can queue up all
this but you look at the home page you
click on a video maybe you go back to
the home page and see the same videos
your state has changed you've done
something different so it's a different
event so from our perspective
you only get you only choose one item
per parade so that's perfectly fine the
second assumption is that the state
transitions and the rewards a
probability of going to the next state
from the current state depends only on
the item that the user selected not on
the items that they not on the items
that they do now and and the reward as
well depends only on that item the
reward that's okay we're interested in
how you engage with videos that you
consume the state assumption is probably
it's only an approximation of reality
the videos that I showed you that you
didn't click on can have an impact on on
your state but kind of a first
approximation this isn't a lot and
unreasonable practical practical once
you do that the details aren't super
critical the paper you I mean it you
could all derive this two seconds with
that you actually get a full
decomposition of the Q function okay in
particular here I'm just showing the on
policy what is the value of a slate at a
state given a fixed policy PI it just
decomposes into this nice expected value
of these item wise these item wise Q
values so we're gonna call this thing a
Q Bar says what is a long-term value of
a user consuming item I write
conditional on them clicking it okay and
that thing so that's what Q Bar refers
to given a fixed
where that thing depends in the obvious
way on the value of the thing to notice
here as well is that we're taking
advantage of this user choice and these
models are actually we learn these
things all the time all the time from
data okay you can think of it as a PCT
our model here are three five items on
the slate is capturing interactions what
does the probability user we click on
this one okay and I should mention I
think I forgot to mention it we always
assume that there's a null atom on the
slate so these are and always so not
choose anything right so we just don't
we don't treat that especially we just
assume that there's special item on this
so this is all very nice I won't go in I
won't go into the details but it this it
now suffices to just learn these item
wise cue functions okay we don't have to
learn the cue function of the slate we
can compute that on the fly from the
item wise from the item wise Q Bar
function just in the interest of time
let me go through this but you know the
the Q value update for kind of TD on
policies sarsa style updates is very
straightforward and you can do the same
thing if you want to do full Q learning
the only difference here is that we have
to throw in this max okay and this is
the second problem that we face we want
to do this maximization right we
actually have to find out of all
possible slates of items we have to find
the one that optimizes this expected Q
value this decomposing right so now
we've got a combinatorial optimization
problem we have to solve it at serving
time obviously we want to compute this
late but we have to solve it at training
time as well with every s a where a is a
slave si s primed our tupple we have to
solve this optimization problem to be
able to do a human that's potentially
problematic right but it turns out at
least depending on the user choice model
that this actually has a nice tractable
a nice tractable solution okay so if you
think about this problem it's actually
very similar to a product line
optimization or an assortment
optimization problem where you users are
making choices based on characteristics
of the individual items but to a vendor
each item has some profit or revenue
that it generates and I want to put
together a slay put products on my shelf
that are going to maximize the expected
the only difference here is what we're
trying to do is maximize the future
expected value of these items for the
users but otherwise it's formally
equivalent to these problems so we can
formulate it it's just the typical way
to formulate it as a fractional mixed
integer program here this would work for
a say a conditional logit or multinomial
logit model and various generalizations
don't worry about the details it's
untitled to make you borrow and take the
table next one yeah
woke up right not optimal unfortunately
yeah so yeah well I'll show you right
it's not bad actually from a practical
perspective but you do pay alright but
the key thing is so when you look at
this say oh that's that's you know it's
a mixed integer program that's bad it's
fractional that's bad right but it turns
out that you can relax this right so the
relaxation gives you a fractional linear
program right and and and and it's it's
it's still optimal it's got them
properties and once I've got a
fractional linear program I can apply
this something I discovered a few years
ago charns Cooper transformation for
turning hyperbolic or fractional
programs and help ease you get this
really nice LP right so you can actually
now solve this thing
during training very fast at serving
time maybe not quite fast enough right
so what you might want to do is do
exactly what you said maybe you want
simpler computational strategies okay so
one thing you could do is not you don't
necessarily want to sort by the cube R
values but the cube R values times the
attractiveness of the item to the user
it's kind of like an expected value
calculation and just sort your your n
items and choose the top okay you might
actually want to be greedy because every
time I put a next item on the slate it
changes the calculus of the probability
so I could just have a greedy algorithm
that throws the next item on that
maximizes maximizes this turn
neither of these have any quality
guarantees they actually have unbounded
approximation ratios right so that's
that's why we're a little wary but
you're absolutely right in practice okay
so just oh good we're pretty much on
time so we won't we did two sets of
experiments so first some synthetic
experiments cuz we wanted to have full
control to see whether or not this
actually worked depending on
characteristics of the environment and
then we did some live experiments in
YouTube okay so in the synthetic
environment I won't get into the details
at all it's kind of a we're actually
hopefully by the end of this month
releasing a configurable recommender
system simulator where you can actually
apply RL algorithms configure users have
particular types of dynamics and play
around with RL algorithms play around
with new recommendations we think the RL
community needs something more than a
joke Oh
but very roughly
we've got documents that we're
recommending so those are just there's a
distribution over documents they're
characterized by some topic vector users
have interests over of interests their
point in in in this space as well so
it's kind of an introspective over
topics and user vector users also have
some inherent satisfaction right are
they happy or not so happy with the
recommender with a recommender and the
items don't the the items of the
documents don't just have topics but
they also have a quality score right
some are kind of crap user and are in
terms of user interaction when they put
a slate in front of a user they're more
likely to consume items on the slate
that they're interested in okay
and the thing that makes an interesting
RL problem is the user state dynamics so
when a user consumes an item their
interest stochastically and can go in
either direction but it's nudged a
little bit at least elastically towards
that the thing that they just consume
okay their satisfaction also changes it
increases or decreases stochastically
with item quality higher quality items
are more satisfied lower quality items
they become less satisfied alright and
if they're less satisfied they're more
likely to terminate their session more
quickly right it's implemented by saying
the user has a time budget which which
goes down more rapidly the less
satisfied they are okay and this is
interesting because we've got a
distribution over documents such that
the quality scores of these documents
are correlated with the topics okay so
there's this interesting trade-off to
include increased satisfaction to keep a
user more engaged for a longer period of
time you'd like to nudge their interest
towards higher quality topics but if
they're not all in it ready interested
in them they're less likely to consume
so it's a true planning planning based
trade-off so just really quickly I won't
go through what all of these different
algorithms are but as you can imagine I
can do q-learning I can do kind of
one-step sarsa and realize we've got
three different algorithms for computing
off optimal sleights we can do top K we
can do greedy or we can do the full LP
based optimization
and if we're doing q-learning we can mix
those up at we can use the full LP
optimization at training time and use
top K at serving time for example or
vice versa
okay what for for like in a YouTube it's
really hard to parametrize it it's hard
to parametrize a policy a policy
basically has to say out of all of these
videos right choose choose this
particular slate in this state it's also
very hard to train I mean I don't know
we can do off policy policy gradient
right but we really have to train purely
offline we don't want to we don't
actually want to do much training on
we definitely do a we definitely do a/b
testing but we want to do as much
learning with the massive amounts of
offline data that we already have
without without relying on a/b testing
to you know to do policy improvement
we'll do it be testing to the validating
verify and in particular because in real
life I mentioned this stochastic action
set right we have these stochastic
action sets right so nobody there's no
fixed set of actions that we can put a
distribution over right it's a different
setting even in the same state yeah
I have a simple question the null slot
is is it equal to somebody going to the
entire slate not clicking on any action
and oh is it closing the app or no it's
just not it's just not clicking on think
conceptually think of it oh they just
hit a refresh right there's a lot more
there's more there's actually a more
complicated story because you two
recommendations it's not just the
homepage like you know you the homepage
then their watch nexor committed they
can search I won't go into the long
complicated story so the point is I just
want to draw your attention to say Q
learning with optimal training optimal
serving compared to not a non RL based
solution where we just myopically
optimize user usually we see some
differences statistically different
significance is in performance it
doesn't look that great but the thing is
it's very easy in the synthetic model to
keep users users engaged so what we do
is we actually compare their performance
relative to a random baseline and what
we see is that the lift you can get my
op from being optimal sequentially is
about more than twice as much as the
lift that you can get by being my so we
think there's the there's a lot of value
and actually optimizing over the long
term when interacting with users
the second thing that we did was look at
robustness to the user choice model so
if if you didn't notice the training
procedure itself has a user choice model
baked into it right that optimization
procedure and maybe you got it wrong
maybe it's not a maybe it's not a
conditional logic model right maybe it's
a cascade model maybe it's something
else now you can put a different
optimization method within the training
procedure that's perfectly fine but you
may always have it may always have it
wrong so we actually want to test
whether or not this strategy is robust
to errors in these are in the user
choice model right so we actually train
the model using using the multinomial
logit or the conditional logic model but
we actually had users and our simulated
users use a simple exponential cascade
model to make the choices from the slate
so it's a very different swing so we
lose some value but we still maintain
the improvement over or the my often
okay so we think this this process is
fairly robust and finally just to test
how how successful this would be
compared to full-blown q-learning in
principle if we just took every slate
and treated it as anatomic item
q-learning should learn the optimal
policy all right but like I said
exploration generalization data
efficiency are going to be problematic
so that's why we use a very small test
case here because we actually wanted to
do full-blown Q learning where we
enumerated all of the distinct slates
and what we see again is that here here
we're not even doing full Q learning
with the decomposition we're just in
kind of one step one step sarsa and it
still does a better job in full human
and this curious sort of committing to
one particular user model and then
imagining that users obey something
else's it's kind of my D is still less
damaging than having the the more real
situation where you have a mix of users
that exhibit all kind of behaviors and
I'm kind of more curious about it again
then when my function fitting has to
make all these trade-offs about like
which users to so like if I didn't
confirm to the user model will I be the
one who gets like crappy recommendations
that's right so so one way one way to
interpret this I mean it's it's it's a
great question what you know what we're
really interested in going back to the
very first part of the time we actually
want to adapt our interaction strategy
to the personal idiosyncratic
characteristics of individual users so
if the way you respond it's out of these
choice models work it's really it's
something about your kind of immediate
preference and if I can do a good job
not just understanding your immediate
preference but also basically your
behavioral characteristics we can
actually fit this model to your where
we're nowhere near that but that's
that's the but even if you get it wrong
the thing the thing that I yeah the
thing that I'd note is we're still
getting we're still doing a better job
we're getting it wrong for everybody
we're still doing a better job than the
current state of the art which is purely
my right is if you for instance in that
experiment say just for some of the
users switch space yeah right yeah but
those users still be better off compared
to that it's it's a good question my my
guess is yes but they don't say that
with confidence because because you know
we're building a
you know here these are very synthetic
experiences in general we're building a
complex function approximator
and you're quite right it could just
skew things so that we're not serving
particular users well yeah yeah this is
the last less slide so just to just to
quickly wrap up so we did try this in a
large-scale experiment with with YouTube
using this to optimize slates on the
YouTube homepage we won't get into all
the details of how you manage home page
versus watch next recommendations and so
on and here what we're showing here
we're just here we just did kind of
sarsa one-step policy improvement not
full-blown q-learning
and just use top case serving okay to to
your point because it was very tractable
and what we're seeing here is the for
this particular using user engagement
metric that we're trying to optimize for
over a longer horizon the kind of a
session style horizon wasn't super long
what we're seeing is the improvement in
this engagement metric relative to the
to the the baseline myopic pulse what
we're seeing is some pretty significant
gain so a 1% improvement in any metric
in YouTube is actually pretty hard to
- come let me skip over this here we're
showing we were basically doing a lot of
rear ankang we actually weren't going
through full collections of items we're
kind of focused on the things that
YouTube would have recommended
recommended and just rewrite them a
little bit and what we see is we're
actually rear ankud are getting that are
getting engaged with they are we're
doing the right thing it's moving them
to the top so in the interest of time I
won't talk any more about slate queue
but I do want to just maybe leave this
one slide up we actually think there's a
lot of really interesting questions that
the RL community we don't know how to
solve in the RL community really well
you know well-equipped time let's take
all questions offline and then we'll be
back in just about a little over say 12
minutes for the